hi friends this week I'm sitting down
with Edie Lattimore he's an ex
professional boxer who's also a
physicist it's not the most typical
combination of characteristics that
you're going to find he's a very
interesting guy
Edd's and me spoke an awful lot about
sobriety
alcohol's indoctrination into modern
society and how it negatively affects a
lot of people's lives without them
really even noticing it we also move on
to his strategies for being incredibly
successful on Twitter which will be very
useful to those of you that are looking
to grow your social-media followings as
we move into the new year other than
that I just found him an incredibly
charming and very likable guy he's
obviously got a big message that he
wants to get across and it's nice to
hear someone who's also singing from the
same hymn sheet of sobriety as myself as
always please share the episode with a
friend if you think that they would
enjoy it and I wanted to give a special
thank you to everyone that helped share
the episode for relationships one of
three so we landed in the top 40
worldwide on the Apple podcast chart
which is ridiculous so thank you very
much I really do appreciate it here is
mr. Edie
Lattimore
[Music]
add a lotta more how are you today sir
I'm fantastic man how are you I'm very
well thank you
so a next professional boxer who's also
a physicist that's that's not a
combination eat here everyday all right
yeah you know these things just kind of
happen you know I I didn't I didn't plan
I wish I could look back like a god man
six years ago this was the plan but no
it really really just kinda grew and
developed as a result of me taking and
putting just one footing from the other
I didn't really know exactly where I was
born but I knew where I was but I was
leaving if that makes sense yeah I
totally understand so I mean you've got
a you got a super interesting story as
you say the those two interests don't
often mix so would you be able to give
the listeners some background to
yourself and tell us your story how you
went from wherever you came from to
where you are now oh yeah no problem so
so I'll give you the the abridged
version and by bridge that I mean the
version it starts roughly around age 27
26 27 I was I was a pretty good amateur
boxer and as I started inching closer I
was like okay I need to make sure I got
something on so far back home because I
started to really see you know the
higher but you getting the closer you go
to being professional you get to see
kind of what the professional ranks are
like business and athletics was plus you
know buzz I was fortunate in the
position I was in and that I was I was
getting sponsored and paid pretty well
but by some pretty powerful people so I
got the seed and I said I need I need a
backup and I kind of put that on the
back burner for a little bit and try I
moved I got cut from the program and I
moved back from where I moved back to
our lived I lived in Los Angeles in the
United States and I moved back to
Pittsburgh and I was working for a while
and going out partying every night just
really being a fool and kind of ignoring
the fact that I didn't have any real
like way to make money other than just
showing up and pimping out my time to a
customer service rep or as a customer
service rep so I woke up I said you know
what
I'm gonna join the army and they're
gonna pay for school and that's what
happened and along the way I spent I
spent 22 weeks away from everyone
because of you know because the basic
training and AIT I joined the National
Guard version of the military automation
of our division and when I when I was
there I realized also that I had
developed a problem with alcohol because
I wasn't around drinking for that that
long and I got to really sit and think I
think alone it wasn't a lot going on in
my mind just what was around me and so I
said yeah this is crazy so I think I got
out I went out and celebrated one time
got totally shit-faced and I said this
is not how I want to go and this is not
how I want live to be I mean life to me
so I got sober then during school and I
would listen I was three you know as a
professional and then I got out and I
just kept going and kept blowing I was
originally gonna become an engineer and
I took my first physics class and I said
I really want to study this not
engineering and that's that's how it how
it happened I think you know I'm I was
fighting and going to school and in the
military all the same time and looking
back at now I have no idea how I got all
the energy I was gonna say that's an
awful lot to pack into a day oh I think
you know my days I remember I mean there
was a period of time and I'm really
grateful because I have a great great
girlfriend and she really helped out a
lot but there was a period of time I
mean I'd for at least a year maybe I
just I mean I mean I know it happened
obviously because I'm here but it was
all a blur because I know it was waking
up go practice go to school come back
our get school practice more come back
work on the homework because physics is
not some slouch subject it was a lot of
studying her homework I had to do and
then some weakens I had to go do
military things so I didn't have that
time either and I was exhausted all the
way through and then I'm still trying to
be like a reasonably social person you
know so life is white life was just just
busy man
that's yeah that's one way to put it
that's definitely busy so was there a
was there a specific turning point where
you realized obviously you'd mentioned a
a period of isolation away from perhaps
access to alcohol and then whatever the
influences were that we're encouraging
you to party as well that that had
highlighted that you maybe had a problem
with substances was there an aha moment
or was it a gradual oncoming and a
gradual onset of realization well in
terms of a specific aha moment I mean
that the word there were quite a few of
me and event if you want to talk like
real aha moments I had I had a real harm
omen like like two years before I
stopped drinking it was just me being in
denial for a long time and what really
did it what made me finally quit it
wasn't like I was like aw man I'm in
rock bottom I got a bounce up it was
having a go I said okay I am now in the
United States military so now I'm
subject to their judicial system and the
civilian judicial I'm trying to finish
my degree in go back to school so I can
make sure I have a better way to live my
professional career is developing and I
just you know really started dating my
girlfriend who I saw a lot of potential
in and fortune I was right I mean she's
still around today and we're happier
than ever and all of these things I
looked at how far I could go with them
and I knew that the thing that will keep
me back was really the only thing that
had kept me from making moves in my life
before and I was alcohol so it was it
was very easy for me to it was very easy
for me it's for me to see that that had
to go and I was really fortunate too
because I had all that going on I didn't
really feel the the effects of not
drinking per se because I think you know
the biggest thing is I've found talking
to people is developing a new life and a
new identity independent of alcohol I
mean obviously there are there is a
point so what you're physically
depending on the substance but as well
experiencing my observational that a lot
of us we we fall into the lifestyle and
then we miss that we don't know how to
define ourselves we don't know how to
deal with life without booze and for for
a while on me I think that was a thing
that I thought about quite a bit but I
also said okay I got another task I
gotta do so I didn't really have there
wasn't time to waste blowing off steam
you know I was still in that whole like
I don't not me not not really in that
whole like new relationship phase but I
but I was really committed to my girls
so I wasn't trying to go out and and you
know chase women and anything like that
and yeah all these things kind of kept
me away I had enough things pulling me
in another direction that I wasn't there
was there was no way to fall back in
least for the first two years maybe
three really I'm coming up when you're
five this December and uh rather I guess
in under a month it'll be five years
sober and I I know that I didn't I was
fortunate I mean I I did what I
recommend everyone else do but I did it
on accident I feel my time with so many
things different than alcohol and it
forced me to develop a different life so
so I would say my transition off was
relatively smooth but I know a lot of
dials and I like that because because
they miss they miss a life they miss a
purpose they miss a way to fit
themselves and I was I was trying to
build a new me and I was you know balls
deepened into a lot of a lot of new
stuff man yeah I got that completely I
think an awful lot of people's reasons
for drinking their habitual an
idiosyncratic rather than dependent at
least in the beginning and then as
you've as you've alluded to there the
dependency the physiological requirement
for your body to have the alcohol and to
keep it going almost comes that's the
second wave effect which yeah which
oddly is is even tougher to break but
then when you layer on top the fact that
that is your life this is the way that
you operate this is
the friendship circles that you've got
in the community and what you're used to
doing and the places you go and the
people you see when that is all hooked
around a substance which you're also
dependent on I mean it's a it's no real
surprise that people struggle to get
themselves clean from alcohol I don't
think oh for sure and on top of that man
we have a we have a very alcohol I wish
I could just say alcohol friendly right
society but we have I'm not full-blown
conspiracy on this the tinfoil hats on
out just yet but but we really have a
culture that promotes excessive drinking
for poor teenagers and young adults and
that's a really formative time because
that's where everyone is building
friendships and really trying to develop
the idea of who they are and so when we
intertwine such heavy drinking and that
in that phase I mean to make it part of
part of their life from 18 to 24 easily
just by the phone you want you have to
try to avoid it at that point and most
people just turn off or they want to
socialize they want to have a good time
but they don't realize how to control it
really can get that's oh I couldn't put
not agree more I've got a couple of
stories I'd be interested to hear your
thoughts on them so the first story is
that I did my Master's dissertation at
Newcastle University in the UK and my
dissertation title was the effectiveness
of anti alcohol advertising on students
at Newcastle University and the crooks
of the the synopsis of what I discovered
was that there's pretty much nothing
which effectively reduces drinking for
students that these terrible stories
after a night out are worn like badges
of honor the whole section of my
upcoming book where I talk about that
where you are you are treated as a a
goddamn hero
absolutely for being a fool if
let's say let's say that me mean you
were catching up next week and I've gone
on an eye out and you go so Chris how
was he not out on my head man honestly
it was unbelievable
Jonathan ended up in hospital he's lost
an eye and ela are lovesick you like in
no other scenario would this be somehow
worn as a badge of honor but it's a rite
of passage for young people to grow
through this excessive drinking phase
and then you know you can look to films
like The Hangover where the this
drinking to access the memory loss the
amnesia all that sort of stuff
it's totally glorified and the problem
is that because because it's so
well-established within our society it's
impossible for people to imagine that
things could be another way so this
leads me on to the second part of the
story which I'd love to hear your
thoughts on so recently I was doing some
doing a casting for a TV show in the UK
as a part of that they asked me for a
lot of background information from what
was your relationship like with your
parents to where did you go to school
what did you like doing when you were
growing up what sort of girls do you
like and blah blah blah and I told him
about everything you know was as
transparent as I was prepared to be and
mentioned I like to do stints of
sobriety I've been sober for about 3
months now I did six months at the start
of this year I did six months at the
start of next year and I'm currently
under doing 18 months I like it as a
tool for productivity etc etc and she
goes away Rings be back in a couple of
weeks and says the producers would
really like to see you in London but
they've asked me to ask you a question
before we bring you down I'm really
sorry I don't you get offended by this
but they've asked me to ask you and
they've asked me to be very specific
about the way that they that I bring it
up as well I'm like okay I mean is this
as one of my ex-girlfriends got in touch
or you know like what what what have
they got on me here she says look I need
to ask you this outright so they brought
up the sobriety thing and they've asked
me to ask you about whether or not
you've ever had a problem with
substances or a dependence on alcohol
and I started laughing down the phone
and she was like what why are you
laughing how's that well firstly I can
tell you I've never had
dependence on alcohol I'm not a massive
drinker although i binge hard when i
party as a lot of us do but what's funny
is that TV executives at one of the UK's
biggest television stations cannot
imagine a world in which someone would
elect to not drink without having a
dependence on the substance you know
it's like the old same right alcohols
the only drug where if you don't do it
people assume you have a problem you
know and nowhere else does that ring
true and and really sometimes I think
about that like how bad you know was
that man I think my behavior was was
just was terrible I do think that but in
but in terms of like I mean I was never
like oh man I got a drink today it just
really turned into a habit that was
difficult to break and then I started to
build a lifestyle around said habit so
for all intents and purposes I mean sure
maybe I didn't have to think about it
but I was putting myself in a position
to not have to think about it so I could
just go drink whenever I want and drink
as much as I want I bring that up
because I wondered sometimes you know
that I have a problem or was it just
easier to say that to move into the next
phase right to go okay let's let's treat
this like it's a real big deal and
attack it as such and you know it'll get
people to kind of look and go you know
because because I find this out when I
say I did there two things you can say
right now people have a very different
reaction though it says the exact same
thing you can say I'm not drinking
tonight or I'm sober and people question
the first one they tend to give you a
bit of a of a lot of a nod of agreement
on the second one in fact I usually give
congratulations which is weird yeah but
we we really have this this culture man
like people don't have an alternative
because I really there's no vested
interest in showing people an
alternative I'm
you are crunch numbers for a chapter
that I'm not going to include in my book
because I don't want people we live in a
climate where you can't say a lot of
things and you'll see worms when I'm
warm one with this and I didn't want
that to be the focus at a book that
particular passage because I know
somebody will rip it to shreds and go I
have to go for the jugular on it but i
but i crunch the numbers on on alcohol
abuse and its correlation with sexual
assault and alcohol abuse and the income
the universities receive selling it at
football games wherever right and it's
not you know on the ladder it's it's not
that great I was really surprised about
that actually but mostly because they go
out of their way the law enforcement
kind of gets involved but on campus
it is very easy how to to get to get out
far and I know over there in the UK you
know the drinking age is different and
this is not an issue but in in the
United States many college towns and
college campuses is a liquor store or a
place to buy liquor on every corner and
you got our one I've seen so many places
shut down throughout the years right
here in Pittsburgh alone for for serving
underage and eventually getting caught
too much money involved I mean you don't
want to leave that alone to the other
fact right it was rough analysis and I'm
a physics guy so my math isn't isn't bad
it just wasn't as rigorous as is you
know I'd have to make it to hold up and
unofficial publication but you know I
figured out that if you eliminated the
road and alcohol if you eliminate
alcohol for me from the equation right
that you would you would effectively
eliminate and when I say effective
eliminate reduced to below ninety
percent are below ten percent the amount
of sexual assaults on women any ages of
eighteen to twenty-four to college age
group and no one wants to discuss that
because the minute you say that you get
the counter-argument you
just tell guys not to do this you notice
that the other and I might look I don't
think any guy is walking around thinking
I rather I will say if we were to break
it down statistically like 1 in 500,000
maybe 1 in 1 million guys are walking
around well you know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna get her a drunk and rape her
like I don't I don't think guys are
thinking that what I think happens is
that of all it's supposed to cloud your
judgment we've got tons of studies that
alcohol ruins your ability to read and
interpret cues that you would normally
pick up when you're sober and it ruins
and likewise it ruins your ability to to
put out the proper cues that you would
when you were sober and you get two
people together in the sexual prime of
their lives and they're 18 and 24 and
you mix in a bunch of wrong and that's
just I mean that's a powder keg and we
see these things happen year after year
after year it's to the point whenever I
hear when I saw it on campus my first
thought is well how much were they drink
I wonder how much I wouldn't know how
much alcohol add in the system yes yeah
and there always comes out it was that
some kind of party or some wow and you
can't it's crazy that you can talk about
that and that would make a difference
like if these people really concerned
about the safety of their children the
safety of their daughters they will be
all over that issue but we were so
trained to not talk about all rather
we're so trained to place a victim and
place of blame on a thing that we can we
can assign like a gender and you can you
can personify a person a lot easy thing
and then you can personify alcohol and
it's like what people are looking for in
these situations is they're looking for
the archetypal roles the villain the
maiden you know the redeemed etc etc
they they want to be able to personify I
recently went to go and see Jordan
Peterson live and he spoke about this
personification of objects within
culture and you know why does Thomas the
Tank Engine have a face but he's a Tank
Engine he doesn't need it right
he doesn't need a face doesn't need a
name but he kind of does because we need
to know what sort of a person Thomas is
despite him
obviously not being a [ __ ] person
like he's a tank engine but the same
with this we need in news stories there
needs to be this personification and
it's you're totally right with what you
say that I think the main problem is
that we can't it's the wood hiding
amongst the trees with regards to this
alcohol problem right you know it's
funny that the title of the chapter was
the drunk elephant in the living room
and I decided that I don't want to put
it in because I don't want people to
miss the other things that I'm trying to
talk about and offer to people well you
know a way to look at your behavior and
you know get through the emotional the
emotional distress I think of sobriety
because that was very surprising yeah
that is I mean that's it's harrowing
that that's the case book we've all been
there we've all been in a situation
where we've had too much to drink and
our judgment has been skewed and we've
made a mistake now very few of those
situations will result in a sexual
assault but you know it could have
occurred you've maybe lost your temper a
kebab guy or you've walked out of
McDonald's without paying or you've
stepped out into the road when you
weren't looking but there wasn't any
cars coming or maybe there was some car
yeah you know I mean all of these
situations are lapses in judgment and
the reason that they occur and that you
continue to drink to excess is because
for every drink that you have it makes
not having a subsequent drink more
difficult alcohol yeah alcohol is a
inhibition reduction echo-chamber
as far as I'm concerned like a a
Bayesian updating gone wrong if that
makes sense no no that dude that's uh
that's brilliant nobody to the physic
physicists vernacular therefore you know
no I totally agree and until we can have
that conversation and I don't I don't
I'm not completely given up on humanity
but I I do understand and I'm not I'm
not blind to the fact that there is very
clearly in a you know very real agenda
and and that's hurting people it's not
helping it's hurting no you know I'm not
I tell people all the time I'm not anti
up or what I am is I am I'm anti it's a
ritual recklessness man like it's a
stupid man we drink to excess and and
celebrate it as I think about all the
times that I you know I I'm just lucky
to be here I just wrote in my email I
sent out to my email list sedated and
another universe the coin landed on
another side and I'm I'm doing multiple
jail sentences and my name you know I
just I'm lucky that's all though I am as
lucky absolutely not everyone else is
gonna be so lucky
and that's and as long as we rely on
what I mean who's here to teach people
how to drink responsibly because we've
created this culture where you know you
got to sneak and get drinks and then if
anything you want to be crazy and bad
with it and then then the people who
don't drink are treated like outcasts
and most humans are not equipped
mentally or emotionally to deal with
that so they cave and then they they
want to fit in and it just it's a it's a
spiral of ridiculousness
that isn't going anywhere what's one
more reason the university system needs
the job but it's a secondary one I think
I think it's it's interesting to talk
about talk about the fact that there are
these unseen consequences so to speak
and one of the problems I had so my
background I'm a club promoter I run
club nights you know I've had probably
near to a million people come through
the events that I've run in the last 12
years or so with my business partner so
you could argue that I'm at the tip of
the spear when it comes to delivering
delivering this rhetoric to students but
never once in any of the marketing
promotions that we put out have we said
to drink to excess we're very very
careful and licensing are also very
careful keeping a watch on what it is
that we communicate to these students so
where is this rhetoric of excessive
drinking coming from here's what I'm not
sure about I don't want to speak for the
rest of the world but I do understand
that
out of the for lack of a better phrase
degeneracy norms are common in the UK
and the United States right now so as
far as this excess goes I think is I
think it's a derivative of our
consumerism or consumers ones that we're
very much about more and not just more
but more on display you know a lot of
these kids don't sit in their dorm rooms
and kill a six-pack alone right they go
out and they do it what a bunch of the
people is as part of a of an acceptance
ritual and a lot of that comes from us
being I would argue not trained very
well at connecting with other people as
well so it's really a perfect storm I
think one we we have this incredible
display culture and we have tribalism we
want to fit in we don't want to feel
alone yeah alcohol started as as a way
to do that and then just it just evolved
you know one people keep trying to do we
already outdo one another so we're not
every fret has some kind of binge ritual
and then that spills out into the
mainstream we got money involved so now
there is there is you know you can't
come right out and say go drink a lot
and then bring some more you can't come
right out and say that but but that just
has made the marketers even more clever
you know yeah it got you know we look at
the way I don't know how cigarettes are
hands on over there but you can't have
cigarette commercials here in the United
States anymore they're for a long time
for a long time right there was a big
deal about Joe Camel and Joe Camel the
cigarette God made to appeal to children
I made to appeal to young adults it's a
camel but a leather jacket or and these
sunglasses walking around smoking you
know so so while you're not telling
people go smoke we are we are
associating images of coolness not as a
whole media behind because there's money
I mean they realized that if we get you
to drink this and your movie will pay
you and then the writers make it great
because that's what they do their
writers and directors I said we will go
oh man that's a great time let me
emulate that yeah I think I think you
told you right it's a lot more
subversive when you see it delivered
through the culture in that kind of a
manner and that that to me that almost
below-the-line
delivery through popular culture rather
than the sort of top-down above-the-line
rhetoric from the advertisers direct is
where it appears to come from but I can
also see as someone who's interested in
creative pursuits I can also see that if
you if you cast the hangover but you get
rid of the drinking or if you have like
a bad boy
biker hero in some film but he's having
like a vegan smoothie before he goes to
like shoot someone it kind of loses its
edge a little bit like there's a role
there's a role that alcohol needs to
play in popular culture and
unfortunately again we're kind of stuck
in this echo chamber where there's
nothing else that can fit it you know it
changes the character if you take him
from from saying well this particular
character who has lost his family and is
on a path of revenge is drinking heavily
every night and then waking up in the
morning to go and trying good people
down what if you swap that for that same
guys micro dosing LSD or like you know
smoking weed or taking [ __ ] CBD
tinctures or something like the dynamic
change is too much and it destroys the
story
so this culpable deniability on the side
and also I think genuine deniability on
the side of the people that are writing
these rhetoric sin but it's a vicious
circle because you unless we can step in
at some point that's never gonna stop
yeah and and so so you know we we
already know what happened you know this
country probably ran one of the best
natural experiments in history
destructive but one of the best we know
what happens when you ban alcohol we
witness it we had the 18th amendment
than the 21st amendment it was that bad
that it
put it into an amendment you know and
it's the only reason why we know people
like Al Capone are the only reason so
we're not gonna ban it and there's so
much money involved and it's going to
continue to subvert culture as a result
so the best thing you can do is you know
I'm a big believer in the gym top-down
you know from the generation and and
working with your kids and showing them
a good way to live I have a very unique
perspective because you know I grew up
around a mom that did drink a lot and
the day he was he didn't drink that my
bicep not that much drink you know I
wasn't around them that much before but
alcohol was very much apart from all
I've grown up but not so much in my
girlfriend's life and it's so
interesting to see little things like
sure I have a glass of one and when I
say show up a glass of one I mean sure
we'll have a few sips from a glass and
then it'll sit there and so I clean em
I'm like and I look at how can you not
finish that that's weird
and it's because you know she grew up in
a household where were they they
promoted different values and there
wasn't this condo consumerist
excessiveness and certainly there wasn't
much of all I mean what it's gonna come
down to if we're gonna do anything about
this situation and most first we gotta
seize the situation which I don't think
they ever they're ever gonna do
understand and mass but but if they did
see it then the only solution the one
that will not result in a large severe
negative externality and reaction like
like the days of prohibition is that
it's gotta start in at home with the
families man it's gotta start with with
how you how you raise your children or
what you show them and how you develop
their their abilities and discipline and
confidence all those good things but but
you know we're horrible we live with
that's not that's not gonna happen it's
probably I haven't been to a college
party in man if [ __ ] man that was maybe
26 I don't know 26 25 so I don't I don't
know how bad or how crazy two campuses
getting all I see the extreme news
stories when the man they hit and you
know that's like the airplane
reflect effect you know our availability
heuristic I think is the official name
so I don't I don't know how how bad it
really is but if I had to take an
educated guess based on what I can see
and the ears I have come at that level
oh you know it's it's certainly no
better than when when I was in my 20s
probably easily worse and now now it's
social media man everybody wants to be a
star wants to tag a brand every wants to
show off and you know you will we worry
I don't know how old are you I'm 30 okay
so you're by I'm 33 so you're you're
roughly the same era you know when we
were [ __ ]
we were [ __ ] and you could forget
about it unless you were a really really
big one like you went to jail or
something yeah you know and then later
on you know kondañña
you probably were a little more in this
and I was you know I sent my fair share
of drunk text but that was later into my
drinking like you know our 24 25 now
though man you a fool man it is it's out
there and and not only but but it's not
treated the way it should be treated you
know yeah people wrong but then no one
looks at them something like we're going
oh my god I've got to stop holy [ __ ]
that was awesome I mean the the the
thing that everyone needs to remember is
that you are only ever one email away
from TMZ or WorldStarHipHop yup that's
it what email one email and a couple of
million people see what you got up to
last night so you totally right the the
external accountability and the stakes
have been raised an awful lot more
because of the level of connectivity
that the world's got that you know what
you or me would have had to have done 12
years ago to have made the news like it
would have like people like it would
have had to have been a Armageddon level
drinking Xpress capade but now you know
you can reach an equal number of people
that probably the mainstream news
reaches with a viral video like we've
all gotta fret we've all got a friend
that that randomly that can't did
something funny and got a TED stuck in a
piece of bread or do you not mean like
the fact that you can reach that volume
of people is obviously it's a platform
but it on the flip side of that it's
also a real it's also real concern so on
the topic of the platform of social
media we're going to move on to your
thoughts on Twitter which I'm super
excited to get into but I've got one
thing that I wanted to bookend the
conversation with with alcohol about
actually two things firstly if someone
was considering taking a stint of
sobriety to see how they got on have you
got any first step tips that you would
give them to aid them moving through
that that sort of initial period that
transition phase man you two things one
you're gonna have to just spend time
with different people I've gone back and
forth about this in my mind over over
the past five years
and ultimately if you're serious and you
want to try a different lifestyle you're
not gonna get support from the people
who are still in said lifestyle it's
just it's not gonna happen
people aren't is on that way your
existence and your action will force a
type of reflection that people aren't
ready to make I think the biggest
mistake I made when getting sober was
asking my friends what they thought of
course they're drinking with me they're
not gonna admit the problem I mean very
rarely do you know what we are we know
that not happen right so if you want to
get sober man if you want to try it out
you're gonna have to just accept that
you're a fern group for a moment ain't
your friends go do something else make a
new group have some fun explore yourself
and that leads men to the other thing
you got to immerse yourself in in the
tasks the demands energy because it's
very easy to say I worked very hard
today I'm gonna go have a drink I
actually did have that's not quite a bit
but when you're exhausted I'm working on
stuff plus you know you got promises and
commitments but really when you're
exhausted even if you tell yourself but
when you tell yourself it's temporary
it's very easy to just go okay but it's
over right well I mean I didn't give
myself temporary out it was just right
I'm done but if someone wanted to try
and see how it a debt that how they went
with it that they need to be busy they
really need to be busy otherwise it's
gonna be very easy to say Oh
I did really well today I'm gonna
celebrate with a drink yeah oh I had a
bad day and right I'm gonna I'm gonna
use it as a as an anesthetic or as a as
a pill or is that the equivalent of of
something to dampen that mood down I
suppose which again the I like the idea
of having having a newfound purpose and
something to to put that energy into
that it's a reason to get yourself up in
the morning and it's also a reason to
put yourself to bed at night without
having had a drink if you know that you
got to get up and you got to perform the
next day in whatever whatever value is
that you've chosen is worthwhile if you
know that you need to do that then you
don't want to drink the night before
because you want to be fresh because
you're excited about performing to you
the best of your ability the next day
yeah absolutely so the final thing I
wanted to touch on was I had a
discussion with Michael Kazu who is the
CEO of brute strength
now Michael took his first drink of
alcohol when he was 9 years old had a
very heavy substance abuse to Class A
drugs and alcohol by the age of 14 was
in and out of rehab and then went on to
become the fittest man in the world two
years in a row at the CrossFit Games as
part of the affiliate Cup now he owns
the probably the biggest CrossFit
programing company on the planet which
is brute strength and I talked to him
about his his thoughts on sobriety and
it was very interesting to hear that
what he said or one of the things that
he touched on was that he feels like
beating an addiction or beating a
dependency isn't simply no longer taking
the substance it's the ability to
reintroduce that substance on your terms
now I've spoken to Dominic McGregor
who's the CEO of social chain which is
UK's largest and probably the world's
largest soldier social media agency also
had some pretty big substance problems
that came on much later in life much
more recently and now he's in his about
two years clean I think from all of
those and he wasn't he didn't fully
agree he felt that you can have control
of the substance by still not letting it
in but I'd be interested to hear what
your thoughts are on
on that the reintroduction of the
substance on your terms is nah man you
know here's what I'll say no one no one
decides to get sober because they had a
great experience most of the time and
they had a few bad ones right that's
just a regular might at drinking to
learning your limits nah man
mom I thought so it is once you know I
always say here's what obviously I say
you know as far as my privilege of
alcohol is concerned I lost our
privilege in this life you know and I
want to keep it that way
I you have to leave it behind you have
you make that decision because you know
that bad things happen you know and you
gotta remember it's not even so much a
situation of excess I always say look if
you start doing dumb [ __ ] under the
influence then you know the alcohol is
working that there's no there's no
minimum effective dosage or anything it
we like to tell ourselves that but we
gotta remember we're still at the end of
the day and Justin something that's
supposed to alter way we think and also
our judgment I don't think if you
realize that you cannot do that to the
point where you have to commit yourself
to a program or you have to make a vow
of never touching it
there is no reintroduction to that like
you know I just
i 100% flat-out disagree because if you
get to the point where you feel like you
need to quit then then you then you
don't have control there there's no
control over it what I will say to that
though is if you you know if you scale
back if you think you know like I was
here earlier I'm not sure I had a you
know a pure addiction or not what I knew
is that it was severely and affecting me
and no more I don't want those effects
now you know if I if I made it I was the
man and I decided to go have a drink
you know what is that that do does
is it good or bad but at some point it's
just it depends on a level of commitment
how how committed are you it's also I
suppose as well how how much of a
problem is it because you know for me
alcohol or sobriety the removal and the
abstinence of alcohol for me is more a
tool for productivity I've never I've
never had a dependency very fortunately
I'm around a lot of friends that have
been touched by that kind of a problem
but for me that's never been the case so
when I'm looking at my sobriety in
particular I can see it a lot more
through the eyes of someone that's
elective rather than necessity if that
makes sense it's not a necessity yeah
for me to do it it's me choosing to do
it in the same way as someone saying
okay I'm gonna make sure I get eight
hours sleep and I uh okay I'm gonna make
sure that I eat five bits of fruit and
vegetables a day or whatever it might be
so I think I think that maybe maybe on
that side is there's a number of
different sort of unique approaches but
I think what's interesting is that a lot
of people will be suffering a net
negative from alcohol consumption but
may not be doing it that regularly may
not that you know you could go through
your entire life netting a negative from
alcohol but never actually having
anything go that wrong right you just
end up damaging your health you waste a
bit of time you kind of don't really
develop any passions that are outside of
drinking your weekends get wasted and
before you know it you're 60 and you
like it you know and for some people you
know and that's another thing that's why
I find it really interesting that did
that particular guy said that because
that's that's really interesting to me
yeah you know my personality was such
that or rather is such that I just I
mean I just wanted more for my life and
and now at this point in I think I just
I couldn't imagine what I would get from
it I mean I think I'm the coolest person
most people are gonna meet and I know
that alcohol makes me less cool like I
like I'm not as sharp I'm not as
interesting yeah I'm not as controlled
and so it comes down to the image that
I've kind of learned to develop of
myself
independent of the substance so so I
wouldn't even have and I'm from our
argument is is filtered through that but
I wouldn't even have a desire at this
point to drink again
you know what would I get out but I
couldn't I couldn't agree more so III
announced announced a little Facebook
stay is I kept my sobriety stints quite
quiet for the for the first two but did
a little bit of a song and dance about
because I know that it kind of does
inspire other people or at least make
them think about about drinking I was
interested to hear people's responses
and someone asked me for the reasons why
I wasn't drinking anymore and the number
one reason the very very top reason I
had was I have nothing left to learn
from alcohol right there he had nothing
left that the substance has to teach me
and it's like if you read a book so much
that you knew it verbatim reading the
book kind of defeats the object it's
I've seen I know the page is I know the
fonts I understand where the where this
bits creased I understand what it feels
like when I get to the end and when I
start at the beginning like you know if
move on to a new book with regards to
that yeah you know there's a new face
that you're writing I mean in that
regard to me maybe that's what I needed
to put the book down was was that period
because now it's just I look at that
period of my life like man I wasted so
much time I learned some lessons but
mostly wasted Tom you know now down
let's get on let's get on where they can
get on you know and be productive do
some cool stuff yeah I think I think
what's to kind of finish on that what's
super interesting is that you've talked
about the fact that being sober makes
you more interesting person which is so
counter to what most people would would
perceive oh yeah on your on your blog at
the moment I mean you've got something
about like how to be fun whilst being
sober yeah oh yeah for sure I mean it's
to the point like um I just a good
strong extroverted personality there
there's no other way around it I'm just
I'm just already outgoing and already
interested in life so I'm not I don't I
don't need it you know I don't need it
anymore and so I try to build a life
independent of it and I have a great
time with it well you know it's it's
nice to see that someone who you know is
accomplished and he's getting things
done I think one of the main things that
we need to do if we are going to kind of
open up people's eyes to the topic of
sobriety for for you know elective
sobriety almost we could call it as
opposed to kind of necessity of sobriety
one of the things that we're gonna have
to do is have people who are in you know
it were aspirational role models you
don't want to see some guy who's hooked
up to a machine with jaundice and
[ __ ] liver failure and go oh look at
this guy he went sober and it saved his
life right yeah but first off I don't
want to be in the situation that that
guy was in sorry is in and secondly I'm
not in the situation that he was in so
it's just there's too much of a gap for
people to leap they're cognitively so
you know hopefully hopefully this will
have opened some people's eyes I want to
move on to Twitter and your your
relationship with Twitter would you be
able to explain explain to the listeners
what your what your thoughts are on
Twitter please ah man I think I think
Twitter is like magic I don't I don't
know I I have this this thing I've been
thinking about lately which is that the
the world we live in today is so far
advanced that you couldn't even if you
were a writer and like say 1900s you
couldn't even imagine would be like that
your science fiction wouldn't create
this because you couldn't see this at
all even in your imagination is just so
crazy and Twitter is one of those things
ma'am you know I say a thing I put a
thought out and people share the thought
look like and then those who will share
the five and you can spread a message
around the world and like I mean and
under and under 30 minutes I mean it's
faster than any method of propagation
because of the way they set it up it's
just one giant
growing
self-sustaining metcalfe law-abiding
network and it is just cool I love it
I've spent a lot of time and energy
figuring out how to maximize the use of
this platform and then I think I think
it shows a man the follower counting the
engagement and now to living our make
off of it
I think it's it's just the best thing
ever
you know if Twitter goes away somebody
will come up with something because this
idea of sharing across barriers like you
don't have to follow me to see what I
say but if you like what I say you can
follow me no other platform structure
that way dude just just this it I mean I
write about this I got a new book coming
out and a set of and of course along
with it afterwards what I talk about
this exact thing that makes Twitter so
powerful with that you can you can share
our dishes no other platform that should
do that and then sharing ideas you can
motivate you can inspire you can draw
people when you can antagonize you can
do whatever you want I mean what you
can't do whatever you want in terms of
service exactly right but my thought
about the Terms of Service I mean people
complain about you know sensitivity and
and you can't say it is censorship and
and that's never been an issue for me
because that's not why I would want to
use something as powerful you know what
I mean like that that's really how I
feel about it
I'm not I'm not saying people should be
restricted from saying whatever they
want what I'm saying is that why would I
spend my time on this platform just you
know shitposting and trolling there is
so much more than that problem one did I
take that with a Facebook and bother
some people you know here we we have I'm
sitting here and probably the reason you
know about me and so many other people
know about me is because I have thoughts
and I understand how to craft them and I
just put them out I press a button and
then I can amass a group of people
around me I'm not interested in
violating the terms of
because that's not that's not my stick
I'm not a shock doctor you know I'm not
I'm gonna talk about problems how about
politics
I hate politics uh personally yeah it's
just this is this is a very very
powerful tool it's like it's like the
way I see the Twitter CEO you know and
these these bands and fund these words
and I'm just this is not my my mother I
don't think jack is doing a good or bad
job I think time will tell but what I do
know is that this is a very powerful
technology I'm probably more powerful
most people realize because behind any
any machine are people and this is the
ultimate tool for connecting and finding
people
so without what I think he's doing is
trying to be a guardian of of the new
magic before we abuse it and like lose
it
god that's analogy I would go with not
whether he's making the best decisions
on you know on Guardian it is is a
different debate but I think that's how
he sees his role maybe not consciously
but he certainly understands that he is
the steward of a thing that can and will
change the change the world I mean it's
changed individual lives which means as
a collective it's going to change large
groups and change the world
absolutely so you touched on that you'd
come up with some effective strategies
for Twitter would you be able to lay out
some key elements of that framework for
the listeners who might want to think
about growing their Twitter following or
look at some principles on what's most
effective right above all things man you
have to give people a reason to want to
see your words but like because at the
end of the day that that's all it means
like right now I'm looking at my screen
that that's 62.1 Kay underneath my
followers all that means that I've given
those people that many people reason to
follow and listen to me I provided by
you I've given them something that helps
them something that they didn't know
something to helps them makes them feel
a certain way or think the certain way
they find favorable
at the end of the day of you want to
grow you have to give value and I can't
stress that I love many people when they
start on this platform they don't they
don't realize that that the that if you
want it's like it's like real life but
if you want people to follow you eat
give a reason you know why should you be
my leader I mean that's what I mean they
they call it followers right but they're
you know why should we let you lead us
what have you done whatever what do you
say what have you shown to be the to
separate you from the rest of these
other jokers out here who are putting up
pictures of women and cats and trolling
what do you bring to the table yeah
number one thing number two things you
have to give people to see that you add
value and the only way to do that I've
grown my following from scratch and I
did that I didn't ask anybody to follow
me I didn't I didn't pay for play
nothing like that right this all is real
people and and the engagement shows I do
about twenty five million in presents a
month let me tell you I started like
every other account starts and I grew
because I identify people that I already
looked up to and liked and then the
people who were already following them I
followed a few of them and they were
saying some good and then I will quote
tweet whatever they know things that
they say and add by you to it when you
do that you that they see that you did
it first and then they can decide if
it's worth retweeting or not and then as
you read is they retweeted it soon when
you you have added some great about you
then other people are going to see it
and then it just grows and grows I have
an article how to grow your Twitter
following and I and I got a screenshot I
don't even remember the program I used
on a website that showed the growth of
my my following from beginning to now
plotted on a a time to follow a graph
and you can see it's a nice exponential
curve the way you you would think it
looks and starts out growing slow slow
slow and then then it grab
Julie gets gets a steeper and steeper
slope alright and so now I'm gaining
about 2,000 followers a month I was on a
street for her for 11 months where I
gained at least 2,000 followers and I
haven't gained less than 1500 for our to
less than 1,500 followers in a month I
haven't gained lessen and probably over
two years I have to go back and see and
it will be quite some time so and and
and that the basic strategy is the same
add value add value add value give get
people reason to follow you make them
think about they make them feel
something highlight how a part about but
life for your life take from your
experiences and what you've learned and
repackage it and put it out there
there's so many different places to get
lessons that you should not run out of
you should not run out of ways to add
value really realistically the only
limitation you're gonna have is like who
do you who's presenting your information
to their network right which means at
the beginning you gotta follow more
people not not more but you gotta follow
a decent amount of people you gotta
follow more people then you then follows
you and then they put your stuff and
they go this guy's says some things
let's go follow him
yeah he's and and then they keep
tweeting out and then you just keep
growing and growing and growing I mean
it's really it's really beautiful man if
you do it right you'll just keep
sprouting up I mean next year this time
I'm gonna paste I have a little under
140 thousand followers that is not
insignificant cause it's a good
platformer you're you enable yourself to
reach an awful lot of people I think I
think what's cool there is what what's
accurate there is the fact that you
focused on the fact that you need to add
value and I think what people need to
what people want to hear is well this is
the golden ratio of following to
unfollow ignore that all that you need
to do is x y&z but obviously the whole
point is
you come up with content which is
engaging in which resonates with people
and that requires you to actually think
quite hard and be creative and be
original with stuff okay and add your
own flex that's not an easy thing to
write down on a piece of paper you know
there's all kinds when you look out like
look at influences on ways to go Twitter
I mean people don't like that they don't
know no one really writes about it in
the mainstream because it's not easy it
is the hardest platform to grow on
because you are judged I mean let this
be you know a commentary on the minds of
humanity however you want to take it you
are judged by the caliber of your words
and you know at first and foremost now
there's other things behind that that I
think are are equally as important are
ly are very close
particularly the image you put forth in
your authenticity like you know I always
say I'm the most undocks well man on the
Internet you can literally go look up my
address if you wanted to with the boxing
commission and I regularly give it to
people if they want to mail my stuff I'm
not you can't do anything to me
dachshund was that's not gonna get you
in prison like yeah you don't get my
social security number I'm on my credit
card yeah you gonna jail for that though
but everything else I'm just not worried
about that and that that is the
authenticity I put forth behind the
platform which I know works to my
advantage you know people feel like they
can talk to me and whenever I have a
chance if I'm in the city and some of
those asti you're here here would you
like to meet up I always take the I'm
very grateful because well you have when
you can reach those many people it's
impossible to be broke I mean you really
have to try like I'm not saying you got
a ball out of control I'm certainly not
I mean I make a modest living but but do
you know how difficult how does it how
does a business survive it sells things
and what does it sell means the people
so it needs to market and advertise I
have the incredibly powerful organic
platform plus I only give out things
that are viable I built up such a sum of
us trust only discusses things that are
viable and where I'm writing things that
help people that that if we know when I
create a thing it's not really an issue
like I don't even I mean I is
to the point you know gods have said
like do you know you make a killing with
the paid ads and guys are always trying
to give me a to affiliate and promote a
thing and I arrived to be very very
selective because what they don't
understand is that the moment I
affiliate something I'm putting my
authenticity and reputation on Milan if
you have a garbage product not only are
you not gonna make any money from that
I'm gonna look bad for like I'm trying
to please people you know there's always
gonna be people have a problem with you
making money that these weird as that is
but I don't want to give those people
fuel Allen plus I don't want to fleecing
one in the first place I don't want to
promote a shoddy product that I turned
down way more things than that promote
and I only promote what ya only point
like three things for occasionally won't
win when a buddy of mine drop something
in it because his it would change my
life I used it it changed my life so
yeah but yeah aside from all the
technical stuff which we could get into
that I'm gonna put together in my
upcoming book and course and I'm working
on about you know how to write and how
to structure things and different ways
to weight the words and take your
experience and transmute it to a to a
highly engaging tweet at the end of it
all if you do nothing else you can make
a lot of mistakes and your formatting
your word balance your word choice but
if you deliver value you'll grow you may
not grow as fast as if you you make the
tweet perfectly balanced or avoid
repetition of words but you will grow I
think that's I think that's a good way
to put it that focusing on the small
stuff or sweating the small stuff is a
surefire way to actually not get
yourself off the ground I like what you
said about not compromising and not
doing not choosing to affiliate yourself
with products that you don't fully
believe in that's the same for myself we
have a series that all of the listeners
will know which is life hacks and as a
part of that that is were not affiliated
with anything that we ever feature and
we're just completely transparent about
websites or apps or approaches or
techniques or
products that assist us in our life and
it's stuff that we actually use and
sometimes we'll use it for a bit and
then get rid of it and you know but it's
it's genuinely it's a manifestation of a
solution to a problem that we have found
and I think Farnam Street which is one
of my favorite blogs oh yeah I love
their blog shame parish is a absolute
animal any of the listeners who want
something to believe in
yes you had me on the boy flew down from
Toronto for one day recorder and then
flew back monster so you is that out on
the knowledge project yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's mouth pre a little while about
it maybe a little about a year maybe a
little a stick well I'll make sure that
I put the link to that in the show notes
below as well but there's a there's a
really cool medium article by herbert
liu which says why Farnam Street
optimizes for loyalty not pageviews and
that playing the long game which Shane
talks about so much and focusing on
adding as much value as he can it's it's
such undervalued way of getting to the
top because everyone wants the same as
you know you were talking before we
before we came on air about how you just
gone to the gym and you'd hit the heavy
bag or whatever you know people don't
want to have to go at the gym and hit
the heavy bag they want the 5-minute abs
workout and the pill that gives it to
them and in exactly the same way as this
is why I think one of the one of the
major attractions of reality TV at the
moment is that it gets people from no
platform to huge platform without
actually having to cultivate anywhere
added any added value in the interim you
don't have to craft a character or prove
any sort of worth all you have to do is
exist and as a byproduct people are
interested in your existence so you know
operating and optimizing for loyalty and
not page views is a surefire way to get
yourself a tribe that will follow you
I think what's cool now is we're
starting to see things stratify out into
different sorts of media so you know if
you're good on video then you go to
youtube and if you're good with words
and short form bits of kind of Maxim's
and aphorisms and and that sort of stuff
then you go to Twitter and if
you know if you're good with imagery or
you're you know a good looking guy or a
good looking girl or you have the nice
meson Sen or however it is then you go
to waste you know what I mean so these
yes these mediums are now you don't have
to be a jack-of-all-trades
you know most people have got one of
each or at least two of the three big
big platforms but if you're very very
successful if you're a good if you're
good with words and you can articulate
yourself well then you know go on
Twitter or start a podcast if you find
that you're particularly good if you
know if you're ridiculously really
really really good-looking then you can
go on Instagram or you can if you're a
photographer you go on Instagram etc etc
so it's nice that you've found yourself
you've crafted a an arena for you where
you're surrounded by people I mean you
know Shane parish like if you follow
Shane parish Nicholas Taleb Jordan
Pete's and Sam Harris yeah Shapiro you
know if you follow a group of guys like
them and yourself the volume of wisdom
that you're getting hit with it's in the
[ __ ] PS eyes isn't it it's like a
16-bar pressure of wisdom that's just
coming at you on a daily basis and you
don't need to look online you know if
you had Twitter and medium I reckon that
you probably be able to grow yourself
into an absolute monster of an intellect
in no time at all absolutely because
they admire you yeah they're always
adding by you so there's never that
there's never a dull moment between you
know you can get or I mean I really love
Farnam Street is a result of seeing
toulebonne on Twitter I picked up his
books you know and I'm loving as the
books so so would as what is me but but
but think about this this is what I
always point out to one of the things
that really helps you grow is life
experience and you know the more you've
experienced outside of Twitter you know
the more likely people are going to
follow you it's like you know you can't
get famous from social media that's
that's not we don't want to play that
game right
what we want to do is we want to go and
develop ourselves and and have a lot
built up a lot to say and then come and
deliver valuable perspectives on it or
just in life in general I mean I know
I'm the the beneficiary of the halo
effect you know people go it is God he
box professionally in he got a physics
degree and he wrote some books I got to
follow him and and it just it looks it
looks better I mean at the very least
you know people are gonna go what are
you doing here Wow who cares about you
it's like well I'm here because I earned
it why are you here yeah I couldn't
agree more I think what's cool there is
saying that saying that you shouldn't
aim to get famous through social media
that the fame should come as a byproduct
is exactly the same as saying your body
should not be the purpose of your
training routine it should be a
byproduct of it you should train hard
you should do what you like to do and
you should put in the time in the effort
and then when you look in the mirror it
shows if you reverse it and you aim for
the top of the mountain then you get
lost along the way there's this cool a
really cool quote that you talk there
about why should people listen to you
and everyone wants to be able to
expedite their route to success right
they want to be able to where's the
shocker what's the the you know ed
Lattimore's five quick tips for a you
know twitter success they don't know
here that you need to tweet I mean am i
right in thinking you thought that you
thought you do like a thousand tweets a
month something like that 1000 and 1500
is generally world war hour for so I
mean that's [ __ ] Terry that's like 30
to 40 a day massive volume people don't
want to know that they have to put that
work in but you know for people to talk
about why don't they why should they
listen to you there's a a quote by
Johann Wolfgang von Goethe which says
all truly wise thoughts have already
been thought a thousand times but to
make them truly ours we must think them
over again honestly until they take root
in our personal experience and what I
think this refers to is the fact that
there isn't there isn't a a shortcut to
getting life experience like without
context or buy-in
even the most enlightening concepts
don't resonate that's why your life
doesn't change right when you see one
inspirational quote on Instagram it
needs to be part of a bigger narrative
it needs to be part of a bigger picture
and you know seeing one out of context
quote it's it's not enough
it's immersing yourself in good content
like you say people who had value guys
like yourself and Shane and Nick Talib
and you know like those the volume of I
can't get over what I look at when I
look at my Twitter feed I actually
wouldn't followed a dream I want to
followed everybody on my Twitter and I'm
now following 30 people
which was for me it's just a much more
curated newsfeed you know a lot of the
time what my friends are putting on
there that it's retweet like my friends
and my real friends I have them on
Facebook and that's great but what they
put on Facebook is usually stuff that's
actually meaningful I bought a new house
I've got a new car me and the Misses are
getting married what they posted on
Twitter was just like drop like [ __ ]
just did great like dissolve in my brain
because I think for a lot of people
Twitter's kind of the it's the the last
thought at the bottom of the rung for
for many people because it's a little
bit more nuanced and the fact you've
only got a limited number of characters
means that you you kinda need to work a
bit harder as well so yeah my I mean I
am and I am sorry to my friends that I
unfollowed but I've got you on Facebook
for a good reason but you were posting
[ __ ] and you know I post I also post
[ __ ] but you don't need to follow me so
I absolutely love today add when is
you've got a number of projects on at
the moment tell us the timeline of the
the big main I guess two big main things
or one is my book about the transition
to sobriety I call it sober letters to
my drunk self and I wrote that me as
that as the title suggests I wrote it
just a series of essays that I wish
someone had wrote to me five years ago
and I put it together and now with me
moving along which is which is great the
last things I just got to get I asked
two last things I get the final file to
upload to Amazon and I gotta go record
the audiobook because now I understand I
mean more people just do the audio thing
and I'd be foolish to not do it that way
especially with this kind of book so
there's that and I want to release that
on my sobriety date which is December
23rd the other thing I have set to come
out is I have an e-book on writing
tweets particularly you know how to have
them it's called engagement as the new
cocaine I'm really really excited about
the cover I it's gotta get that strong
market he looked to it I don't know if
you've seen the cover floating around
haven't yet no internet but but it's
really cool and I'm just gonna be
talking about how how I think about
writing because what's happened is when
you write this many tweets you I'm not
sitting there crashed on a perfect win
every time
I just I know I just think in a certain
way due largely to the influence of the
platform and from there I've reverse
engineer and I thought about it and
looked at some things and and there are
definite patterns it's to the point now
where I like I can I'm surprised
when a certain tweet does not do well or
does really well anybody but it's
happening for you and for you like I
have a pretty good idea of like what its
point of resonating how it's gonna
resonate based on the topic and the way
it's written the way it looks is
important people don't realize that so
so I'm putting all that together I think
people want to get you know get a lot
out of it and just like it's a bit of a
marketing lesson here on the side so so
I know what I'm gonna initially price it
I it's part of a deal with a guy I'm
working with they're gonna be 25 bucks
right I'll probably pop it up to like 37
or 42 or whatever those weird numbers
are but but think about this for a
minute
I have a sixty two point one thousand
followers if I get two percent of them
they then then I you know I've made more
than and and and the the the advertising
is built-in I have that many people
obviously I know what I'm doing and this
is the kind of thing that happens when
you when you build a respectable
following and you've done in and you
know I'm people are gonna see how I
think about the platform I saw from like
whatever I made for me what's woman way
more important to me is I just like
sitting there crafting words I'm very
lucky that I was born when I was born
and this technology was created because
it really gives me the ability to craft
our lifestyle and and pursue the things
that I think are important which are you
know knowledge self development health
and really giving something back to
people you know what what good is my
life if I accumulate all of this
knowledge and I do nothing to pass it on
I couldn't agree more I think that's a
really lovely sentiment the fact that
all of our victories and all of our
suffering is that made greater both
greater and less painful by using them
to allow people to avoid the pitfalls
and to expedite the successes that we've
already encountered oh absolutely
you know it's really just a cool thing
man we we got a great we have a great
world there's nothing to be nothing to
be sad about man gotta be happy
thank you very much would you be able to
tell the listeners where they can find
you online I'll make sure it's in a show
notes below but let's get everything
plugged now so I don't forget oh yeah
you know my website is where I write in
my long-form essays that's just ad
Lattimore calm and my twitter is the
same where we were just talking about
you know about put a lot of good stuff
out there I think and that's at
Lattimore my twitter is at ed Lattimore
fantastic well ed it's been absolutely
pretty and good luck with your final
month you've got just about four weeks
to make sure that everything's finished
and ready for Amazon so I I wish you the
best of luck in getting all of that
completed and then once the Twitter
course is out make sure that you give me
a message and I'll I'll make sure
fire out to all of the listeners as well
all right thank you thank you very much
for your time about Quechua
[Music]